so what's the real reason this is being
held up joining me now Wisconsin Senator
Ron Johnson Senator our Democrats
worried about being
held accountable for certain individual
nominees votes
of course not I know this will shock you
and your audience but Democrats are
being complete Hypocrites on this if
they really wanted to accommodate for
the Marines they would just call up the
nomination for a vote first a culture
vote and then two hours later vote to
confirm the nomination it takes
literally no more than four hours but
generally two if you do it as a comeback
vote and you know I think leader
McConnell is completely out of step with
our conference I just feel a great deal
of support for Senator tuberville within
our conference as well as among our base
I mean we are the party of life we're
also the party that upholds the rule of
law and the the simplest solution here
is just have the administration follow
the law have the Department of Defense
not facilitate or you know spend
taxpayer money facilitating abortions
it's just that simple but if they won't
do that all the apps do if they wanted a
general they want one of these
promotions just bring the nomination up
for a vote four hours later that
individual is going to be confirmed all
right well you guys had five weeks off
or four weeks off whatever but as is
customary and in August he had a lot of
time off so presumably again if this was
a national security or military
imperative McConnell and Schumer that
would have gotten together to say okay
we're going to knock out the top 12
people we're going to make sure these
votes are held and we're going to do it
in the course of a day and a half or or
less but I think they don't want to do
it number one because some of these
nominees are pretty bad like the guy
who's tapped to lead the Pacific uh Air
Command
um uh you know the Pacific Air Forces
watch this
ultimately that's really what Dei is
getting after
um you know not identifying the barriers
that are currently exist getting
messaging out to the public as to what
uh what opportunities do exist and then
just you know drawing the talent that we
need to continue to to excel as a force
now are Senators worried about being
again held accountable or going on the
record for this guy's promotion
well first of all this has been a
Hallmark of the bite Administration they
have been nominating and confirming
Democrats have been confirming the most
radical leftists you could ever imagine
it is it is just sad what is happening
throughout all these agencies in terms
of the the people that President Biden
is populating in those agencies but
again Democrats have no problem
confirming these votes and quite
honestly the mainstream media won't hold
them accountable for it so again this is
this is obviously a political issue
Democrats are being complete Hypocrites
and it's just a simple matter of holding
votes and by the way you could hold
votes over Friday Saturday Sunday you
know hold the senate in we can do these
things so again it's it's just gross and
hypocritical I don't think tester I
don't think tester wants to take on any
some of these nominees like the Air
Force nominee you know who's a very
controversial
um Jim's life uh said George Floyd's
death was an Air Force issue or Colonel
Ben Johnson said that white kernels are
largely blind to instant institutional
racism so I I think tester doesn't want
to take that vote I don't think maybe
Sherrod Brown and some you know maybe
Mansion I mean I don't want to I don't
think those guys want to vote for I
think the Democrats want that abortion
issue for the election next year but
thank you for speaking truth to power on
this Senator Ron Johnson hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else